Let's see, to get from start to finish we need to make progress in both the east-west direction
and the north-south direction.
This is my straight line distance.
I can think of it as being composed of east-west progress and north-south progress.
If I can find the legs of this triangle,
I should be able to find this third leg.
Let's see what we can do.
First it travels east at this speed for this duration.
After leg one it's moved 30 km eastward.
In fact, why don't I keep track of this in some sort of table--
progress east and progress south.
For this first entry we make 30 km of progress east and 0 south,
because I'm heading exactly east.
In the next entry, I'm going exactly south at 20 km/h for 1 hour,
which means 20 km south and 0 east.
In the next entry, I go 15 k/h for 3 hours, which is 45 km east and 0 south.
What about this last entry? I'm going northeast 8 km/h for 1 hour.
That would be hypotenuse of 8, but this side actually has both an east component
and a north component.
Well, northeast means I'm exactly between east and north,
so this angle is 45 degrees.
In fact, I can see that cos 45 is going to be equal to this eastward progress--
I'll call this E--over the hypotenuse of 8.
The eastward progress will be 8 cos 45, which is 5.7 km,
and the southward progress will be identical--wait. I won't be identical.
It will be negative. We're not going south here. We're going north.
It'll be negative 5.7 km.
We can get that by looking at the sine of this angle.
Now, let's keep track of total progress south.
That would be this leg of the triangle here.
Well, I'm south 20 but then north 5.7, so this leg has a total length of 14.3 km.
This leg has a length of 30 + 45, which is 75, plus 5.7, which is 80.7 km.
I can do the Pythagorean Theorem to find this side.
I find a straight line distance of 81.96 km.
That's probably too precise. I should probably just say 82 km.